Speaker 1: There's a name that you should
become more familiar with as we move on
and this Republican majority in the House of
Representatives, and that is James Colmer,
Republican of Kentucky. He is the chair of the
House Oversight and Accountability Committee.
An important spot, an important committee
assignment, especially for a chairman.
He has colleagues who will join him
valiantly in their fight to provide oversight
in the Congress. Paul Gosar, avowed White
Nationalist. Lauren Boebert High school
dropout. Multi time fail. Failure at the gree or
excuse me, the Jedi thinking of grad school stuff.
And Marjorie Taylor GREENE, prolific conspiracy
theorist. Q Anon adherent. They're also there with
him and James Comber. The reason I'm saying you're
going to know his name more is because he's going
to be making the rounds. The press is going to
be asking him questions about what his agenda is.
What do you plan to do as chairman of the House
Oversight and Accountability Committee? And you,
I hope, will not be surprised to know that he
even categorizes himself as just an average guy
with average ability. At best, he says, watch this
and then we'll play some other clips, keeping this
particular clip in mind as we move forward.
Speaker 3: And I'm just an average guy.
With average ability at best, that's
fed up with the process in Washington,
D.C. I'm fed up with public corruption and fed
up with the excessive spending, and I want to do
something about it. And that's that's my. Goal.
Speaker 1: Now, look, this could be true. He
could be an average guy with average, average
abilities at best. And some people might be
happy with that. Some people may think, oh,
we need more of a citizens representative
segment of our country. It should be a citizen
government. I believe that to be true. But
there's a certain skill set and intellect level
that you should just by virtue of qualification,
not by some constitutional standard of whether or
not you're able to run for office. But you should
be adept at certain things. You shouldn't be
just an average guy with average ability at mass.
Especially when you're the chairman of the
House Oversight and Accountability Committee,
wrangling the likes of Lauren Boebert and
Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Paul Gosar. Part of
their their their efforts in that committee will
be investigating, obviously, by the name of the
committee government oversight. And he vows not to
be investigating Donald Trump. But and the reason
he gives. Flies in the face of the reason that
he's actually going to be investigating Joe Biden,
it all doesn't make any sense. I don't expect
anybody to expect it to make sense coming from
James Colmer, Republican of Kentucky. Watch this.
Speaker 3: With respect to Trump. You know,
a lot of the media, when I love Pam Brown
and our friends, she's from Kentucky,
went on CNN last night, her last night
of that show. She says, well, you know,
why aren't you investigating Trump's mishandling
of documents? There's a special counsel. There's
a special counsel. And I'm confident that special
counsel is looking at everything and trying Trump.
Speaker 2: With.
Speaker 4: Biden documents, although
it sounds like you are planning on asking the
national so you are asking questions about Trump's
documents, what was in them, how they got there.
Speaker 3: I would I'm going to try to explain
this as best I can. We're investigating
the Biden family for influence peddling.
We learned that they have. Classified documents in
multiple locations. We are concerned. Is that part
of the influence peddling? I don't know.
Speaker 1: Your average guy with average
ability. At best, he can't even keep his
nonsense straight. He's not you heard
him not investigating Donald Trump because
there's been assigned the special counsel.
But he is investigating Biden for the thing. He's
not investing investigating Trump for even though
there's also been a special counsel appointed
in the Biden case. And then he's like, Oh,
let me pause here and try to gather my thoughts.
Let me try to explain this as best I can. Now that
I got myself in this pickle. I'm just an average
guy with average ability and intellect at best.
Emily I believe that was what her name was,
questioning him there. And then when she presses
him a little bit further about other things that
maybe he should be investigating, like what took
place in Memphis with Tyree Nichols, he just says,
Well, that has really crossed my mind. I haven't
thought about that because Joe Biden, it's a five
alarm fire because Joe Biden has volunteered that
they found classified information. He wasn't
hoarding it. He didn't abscond with it as soon
as they found out. They they they spilled the
beans on themselves. But that needs investigated,
not rampant systemic police abuse of
American citizens, unarmed American
citizens. Watch this stupid, stupid moment.
Speaker 3: I encouraged you them to work
with me on the stuff that we're
looking into. An oversight. I
stay out of his business and judiciary.
Speaker 4: Okay, So you don't think it's
necessarily something I was looking into?
Speaker 3: I haven't even thought about it,
to be honest with you. I mean, I was asked
about it. It's a terrible thing, certainly.
There are bad apples in every profession, bad
politicians, bad police officers, and they need
to be held accountable. So I'm confident those
police officers are going to be held accountable.
Speaker 1: He's confident they're going to be
held accountable, but not by him, not by Congress,
not by the chairman of a very powerful
committee. With with so much in its purview.
There's bad apples everywhere. Look, I'm just
an average guy with sub average abilities,
y'all. Why would I look at that? Bad apples. What
horrible luck for Tyree Nichols that every single
armed agent of the state that responded to talk
to address him under the authority and the color
of law. What bad luck that every single one of
those cops happened to be one of the bad apples.
Or is it more likely that the the epidemic
of bad apple dumb in policing in America is
far more advanced that many people would like
to believe? This is a member of Congress who
could do something about it, but instead he's
just an average guy. With an average skill set.